The joe rogan experience,
you know,
it's like,
well,
it is weird.
San Francisco.
Why is San Francisco so empty in Poland?
There was nobody alive back down people.
There was no tech company.
There's very few people.
Chat traffic was nothing back then,
but talk to somebody about what traffic is like in 1960 in la.
I just brought that up earlier,
this show.
Well,
I moved here in 94 and I remember when I moved here,
it was nothing like this.
Nothing.
It's gotten a hundred percent worse.
It's like just twice as many people here.
It is.
What it feels like.
It's so crazy.
You get on the highway on a Saturday night just heading into la on a Saturday
night and you're stuck in bumper to bumper traffic for no reason.
No one's dead.
There's no accident.
It's just too,
I read,
I'm reading a book right now called traffic.
It's about the science of traffic and it,
they did a study in La and Saturday 2:00 PM traffic is worse than any weekday
rush hour in Los has everybody's out.
Yeah.
Everyone's out doing their shit.
Dude.
You know when you go to another city,
like if you go to a big city like Seattle and you're like,
you're there with them and they complain about the traffic,
you can go,
first of all,
shut the fuck up.
Second of all,
what I'm doing must be wrong then because I'm dealing with way too many people.
You guys have got it right.
This is the right amount.
Like you've got a lot of people and be enough.
Too many people like in a medium size city that's not la.
Yeah,
and then traffic makes sense.
It goes in,
it goes out.
Yeah.
Like here it's just like,
hence the scooter.
You want to get out before it gets all blade runner.
He
is not going to happen.
Well,
you know,
it's like those dudes like Magnus Walker lived in downtown La,
dreadlocks in his garage and his warehouse district.
Those guys like that shit.
Right?
He likes that Shit.
He likes being an urbanite.
I'm super fucked.
I'm in Venice.
When that tsunami comes,
I'm super fall.
Yeah,
you're right on the edge.
It's not good for me not looking good.
All the cars are done.
There's will be on my room APP.
What's the APP that wants to give us access?
The early warning APP says you have 60 seconds for your fucking dead.
Cause that was I had in Hawaii.
Well yeah,
there's a,
there's an app now that's working in California,
but the United,
it's the,
you're about to die.
It's,
it's an earthquake's about to hit.
They apparently have it depending upon the magnitude earthquake,
which is really scary because the higher magnitude possibility the more time you
have.
Oh yeah.
They can give you up to a minute to know your Foxville dude.
I'm just thinking what can I,
I'm thinking about one again in a minute.
Nowhere.
Nowhere worth getting.
I can get to like my closet.
Do you have stored food or anything?
I'm embarrassed that I don't,
I have a list of shit I need for a,
probably should probably get for an earthquake.
I don't know.
You must have a whole room of shit in this fucking Palliser.
You're right here.
But here I have meeting here,
but I have,
um,
I do have commercial freezers.
Of course you do with Lpl,
right?
Yeah.
But,
um,
I have,
emergency rations.
Okay.
Have a freeze dried food,
you know,
that could last me a few months.
How would you,
like,
how would you physically get out of the city if you,
Holly,
you would really be fucked,
you said is you just start walking.
What'd you bicycle?
The wheel.
The real fuck would be cars.
There'd be too many cars.
There's way too many cars for you ever see what happened when the hurricanes
were hitting Texas and people tried to escape or Florida like flora the last
one.
You can't go anywhere and they just get stuck on the highway.
You run out of gas and the highways never be scared and desperate.
It's not good in w hurricanes you see common.
This earthquake get 30 seconds,
you know,
I think my scooter is,
is what's going to save me.
It's going to be there.
You're going to go,
you're going to go somewhere.
They're going to eat you.
They're going to get away.
You gotta be with a bunch of survivors.
Yeah.
They're going to hunt you down and put me on a spit.
They're going to keep you alive so they could eat you longer because there's no
refrigerator federation.
Just going to tie you up and cut off parts of you eat it in front of you and to
come here and bust into this.
Fuck yeah man.
That's the move.
Come here.
We'll help you about this space dude,
who has a float tank.
That is so awesome.
Everybody should have one.
I agree.
I just,
my,
my real concern is the,
just that the mass of humans,
just the sheer number is so insane and I don't think it's,
I don't think it's sustainable like this number of people that are,
there's never been a time ever in human history when we've had masses of people
crammed into areas like we have today and not an American.
Our urban areas,
you mean modern America?
Modern Mexico City is like that jammed up.
There's quite a few places that are like the,
the population numbers higher now than it's ever been recorded.
Human history.
And so the population of these cities is higher than it's ever been.
We've never had,
like Matt,
we'd never had 20 million people in a city before in America like we do in La.
What's that?
Jamie states with a smaller population than Los Angeles County.
Is that all of them?
30 something states?
I'm all of them.
Is La County,
20 million people yet it's like 16 something,
right.
I think of it.
This is like on the 10 to 11 million units.
So looking at this,
this map,
and it's one tiny little area of California and it has more people in it.
If it was a state,
then almost every fucking state except Florida,
that and Texas,
Texas,
New York,
Pennsylvania,
Ohio,
and given me Illinois,
Illinois.
God Damn.
And then that is just fucking banana is so crazy.
I don't,
is it,
where would you live if he didn't live?
No,
if I didn't live in,
it's not it.
No.